disculpas el respaldo a las fuerzas del
orden y su negativa renunciar son 50
personas que han fallecido en mitad de
estos actos de protesta y de violencia y
me duele cuando se van a cumplir seis
semanas de protestas anti
gubernamentales en Perú la presidenta
Dina boluarte hizo un llamado a una
tregua nacional para restablecer el
diálogo con los miles de manifestantes
pero atribuyó al caos y la violencia de
las últimas semanas a grupos radicales
reiterando su apoyo a las actuaciones
policiales durante las protestas Pese a
que organismos humanitarios y
manifestantes denuncian una brutal
represión eso es una acción
violento generado por un grupo
de personas
radicales que tienen como agenda agenda
política y económica Este martes los
manifestantes volvieron a salir
pacíficamente a las calles para exigir
entre otros pedidos la renuncia de
boluarte a quien acusan de estar detrás
de las más de 60 muertes durante el
estallido estábamos viniendo por toda
esta Avenida de manera pacífica y de
repente esta policía mira todo diseñada
todo organizada para poder bloquearnos
creen que somos bandas asesinos
terroristas No señores aquí nosotros
marchamos de manera pacífica por el
momento boluarte apuntó que no dejará el
cargo hasta que no se celebre en
elecciones y pese a su llamado a una
tregua los organizadores de las marchas
reclaman su renuncia como condición para
las mesas de diálogo
donde no hay democracia no hay paz Ellos
dicen diálogo pero diálogo para qué Para
para el agua para el desagüe para
carreteras no el pueblo existe acá una
salida política y la salida política Es
que la señora
el miércoles la mandataria tendrá una
reunión con la comisión permanente de la
oea señalando que contará la verdad